bonsoir thomas vous êtes donc devant la
maison blanche à washington
et visiblement il ya du monde il est
beau tout le monde vous l'entendez
derrière moi les effusions de joie qui
part pour la foule une foule de plus en
plus nombreuse ça continue à arriver
plusieurs centaines de personnes
continuent de se masser devant la maison
blanche pour fêter la victoire de joe
biden mais aussi il faut bien le dire la
défait de donald trump beaucoup de
personnes qui sont ici
faites d'abord la défait de donald trump
on a parlé avec quelques personnes qui
sont ici nous il se disait soulagé parce
qu'ils ont passé les quatre derniers
jours devant les médias américains à
attendre le décompte attendre le
dépouillement dans un certain nombre
d'états et les ont été finalement assez
soulagé de voir que la pennsylvanie
était octroyé à joe biden selon le
décompte des médias américains beaucoup
de soulagement donc évidemment
évidemment des mots assez durs pour
donald trump il ya ici beaucoup de
supporters de joe biden et de kamala
harris est important de le noter
ambiance festive avec des slogans tels
que bye bye donald trump il ya des
chansons également qui résonne pas très
sympathique à l'égard du locataire de la
maison blanche
joe biden qui a déjà communiqué c'était
sur twitter il ya quelques minutes il va
s'exprimer ce soir à 20h et 6h
américaine il a pour l'instant célébrer
sa victoire sur twitter on n'écoute
jamais démérité kamala harris
amérique je suis honoré que vous m'ayez
choisi pour diriger notre grand pays
le travail qui nous attend sera
difficile mais je vous promets ceci je
serai le président de tous les
américains
que vous ayez voté pour moi ou non je
garderai la fois que vous avez placée en
moi cette élection est bien plus que joe
biden ou moi il s'agit de l'âme de
l'amérique et de notre volonté de lutter
pour elle nous avons beaucoup de travail
devant nous commençons on a également vu
une vidéo postée par kamala harris sur
twitter et il s'agit du moment où elle
s'entretient par téléphone avec joe
biden l ex s'exprime on a fait on l'a
fait de jeu on l'a fait on a gagné donc
la course à la maison blanche beaucoup
donc deux fous rires
ici ça tranche un petit peu avec les
dernières déclarations de donald trump
ce matin il avait tweeté à nouveau qu'il
avait remporté cette élection est de
loin et juste après que joe biden a été
nommé vainqueur de cette élection par
les médias américains
l'actuel président des états unis a
publié un communiqué ne reconnais pas la
victoire de joe biden qui l'accusent de
se précipiter pour se présenter
faussement en vainqueur écoutez un
extrait de ce communiqué nous savons
tous pourquoi joe biden se précipitent
pour ce faire passer à tort pour le
vainqueur et pourquoi ses alliés
médiatiques font tant d'efforts pour
l'aider
ils ne veulent pas que la vérité soit
dévoilé le simple fait est que cette
élection est loin d'être terminée joe
biden a été certifié vainqueur d'aucun
état et encore moins d'un des états très
contesté qui se dirige vers un
recomptage obligatoire qui pourrait
déterminer le vainqueur final on sait
que ces dernières heures
donald trump avait accusé
certaines irrégularités dans le scrutin
il avait parlé de fraude notamment dans
le dépouillement d'un certain nombre de
bulletins
il ya des procédures judiciaires qui
sont en cours mais à l'heure actuelle
les médias américains sont unanimes joe
biden va devenir le 46e président des
états unis et d'ailleurs les réactions
internationale commence à parvenir il ya
quelques minutes à peine emmanuel macron
s'est fendu d'un tweet ce justement pour
féliciter joe biden merci beaucoup
thomas pour toutes ces précisions